[Música]
en la noche del jueves al viernes el
presidente Gustavo Petro refutó las
acusaciones de interceptaciones ilegales
de parte de su gobierno
acusar al gobierno del cambio de
interceptaciones ilegales es de tamaño y
responsabilidad ningún miembro del
gobierno ha dado ninguna orden de
intercepciones telefónicas el fiscal
general de la nación confirmó el jueves
que la dijin la dirección de
investigación criminal de la policía
interceptó durante 72 horas las líneas
telefónicas de la ex niñera y de otra
empleada doméstica de la jefa de
gabinete del presidente hoy
es un día muy lamentable
para el Estado de derecho en Colombia
Hoy podemos decir con claridad
que
la chuzadas
las interceptaciones ilegales han
retornado a Colombia igual a la
conclusión el ente acusadora aseguró que
un investigador de la dijin hizo pasar
los números personales de las mujeres
como parte de una investigación
vinculada al grupo narco paramilitar
clan del Golfo mientras que la policía
de Colombia emitió un comunicado en el
cual asegura que las interceptaciones
fueron realizadas bajo una orden fiscal
y el Ministerio de defensa señaló que
abrirá una investigación para determinar
los responsables
estos hechos hacen parte de una
controversia nacional que estalló el
pasado 27 de mayo luego de que la ex
niñera María evelis Meza acusará en una
entrevista periodística a Laura Sarabia
jefa de gabinete presidencial de haberla
retenido de forma ilegal durante seis
horas en un edificio al lado de la casa
de nariño sede del gobierno colombiano
para realizarle una prueba de polígrafo
la razón el robo de una maleta con cerca
de 7000 dólares en la casa de la
funcionaria ante estas irregularidades
la fiscalía citó a interrogatorio a la
funcionaria y al ahora embajador de
Colombia ante Venezuela Armando
Benedetti quien resultó involucrado en
el escándalo